-Thanks for having me.
-It's been a while.
Four years ago you were here,
and you were on --
you and Anna Wintour came on
together.
-Yes, we usually make all of
our appearances together.
-Yes, it's so strange
to see you...
-Weird to be here without her.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-When you see Sarah,
you just expect Anna Wintour
to be right next to her.
-We vacation together.
-Of course.
She's a very fun person
to spend time with.
-She is. She's lovely.
-You posted something
on Instagram
I want to ask you about.
Now for those who don't know,
everyone who comes
on this show --
-What Instagram is?
-For Instagram, it's a way --
Can you explain it?
-It's a neat -- it's
a sort of -- hard to explain.
But if there's a picture
you like...
-Mm-hmm.
-And you'd like other people
to see it and maybe they are
people you know...
-Yeah. Sure.
-Or people you don't know.
It's a way...
It's a way of communicating.
-Yes.
-It's a way --
-You know how you used to have
to bring slides...
-Right.
-...over to your friends' house.
-Exactly.
And this way -- it sounds crazy.
I know it's hard to believe,
but you just...
you send it.
-You send it.
-It's the weirdest thing. And at
least a hundred people,
maybe more, could see...
-It's crazy.
-...what's happening
in your home.
-And I was one of those hundred
on something
you recently posted.
-Oh, you were? Thank you.
-You posted a video of
your mugs.
-Yeah. I don't know why.
-Now most people would --
but I was drawn to this.
Because --
-It was a slow news day,
much like today.
-Yeah. I know, that's the thing.
Remember when things were
so crazy that we didn't have
time to take videos of our mugs?
-Oh.
-But you posted your video
and as a guest on the show,
everyone gets a mug.
You get a mug.
-Yes, yes.
-Your husband's been on the show
three times.
-Yes.
-So he has -- I was very happy.
If we look at this mug video,
you'll see "Tonight Show."
You got a "Tonight Show" mug.
-Well, I'm like a mug shot.
-Yeah! But let's take a look,
because there's a couple
"Late Night" mugs there.
Sorry, there we go. There's --
we're coming up on --
I think that's --
-Stuff from Moscow.
-"Tonight Show" right there.
Look!
-Yes.
-There's a -- right there
there's "Late Night."
Right in the front right.
Yep. Right down there.
And there's another one.
-I think --
-So two.
-Yes.
-Okay, so I want to make sure
that the mugs stay in rotation,
so I personalized a mug for you.
-Oh, my God.
-So that's us
on the show together.
-[ Audience "aw"s ]
-Aw.
-And then here's the date
of your two appearances.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-You know...
-Well, that's --
-Are you...Are you crying?
Oh, my God.
I didn't think you'd cry.
-[ Voice breaks ] That's, like,
one of the most
sentimental things that anyone
has ever done for me.
-Oh, my God. That's so weird.
-Hold on a second.
Hold on a second.
Just talk amongst yourselves.
-Yeah.
-No, that's very charming
and dear.
-You know, for my anniversary,
I got my wife a mug.
-The same thing?
-And she was not happy. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, was it --
was it like this?
-It was the you and me mug,
yeah.
-Oh, right, right. I understand.
Details, details.
Well, thank you. This is --
I will have many memorable...
-Drink, coffees?
-Um, libations.
-Yeah.
-Libations.
-Do you drink a libation
in a coffee mug?
-I will now.
-Yeah, okay.
-I will now. And I think a lot
of America,
maybe even a hundred of those
who caught --
maybe I'll be posting this
to my...
-I hope so.
-Hundred or more followers.
-On the next slow news day, this
better be highly featured.
-Please, God, give us
a slow news day.
-Give us a slow news day.
-I beg you.